l'océanic of l'avocat nommé par l'état
ukrainien pour défendre vadim chessy
marine a tout de suite dit qu'il n'était
pas satisfait de ce verdict et qu'ils
allaient faire appel en fait ce cas a
été entendue dans la cour d'appel à kiev
mais uniquement parce que c'était la
seule course où il y avait une salle
assez grande pour accueillir tous les
journalistes qui s'intéressait à ce
calque a été transféré à la cour d'appel
mais ce n'est pas encore un procès en
appel un procès en appel il y aura du
moins selon l'avocat de la défense les
procureurs eux ont dit qu'ils estiment
que le verdict est absolument juste il
avait demandé la prison à vie mais l'un
des procureurs mme a confirmé que même
si valley jesse marine a reçu la prison
à vie cela n'empêche pas la possibilité
de l'échanger contre un prisonnier
ukrainien actuellement détenu par les
russes donc il était minot éminemment
possible que dans les semaines ou les
mois qui viennent il y aura des
discussions pour un échange possible de
vadim chessy marine contre un prisonnier
ukrainien